good evening bread as you mentioned this
is not over yet although the Democratic
Party is claiming victory in this race
their candidate up by a few hundred
votes
[Music]
Connor Lamb the pro-gun Pro Union
Democrat may well have swiped a
congressional seat long held by the GOP
in Pennsylvania's 18th congressional
district though his opponent in this
hard-fought special election Republican
state Rep Rick ciccone warns you know
we're still fighting the fight it's not
over yet we're gonna fight all the way
to in the National Party has his back
prepping for a likely recount attorney
Shawn Logue a ciccone backer watched the
opening of absentee ballots overnight in
Washington County I thought that the
process was flawed there are other
issues that I'm just being informed
about with the machines themselves and I
know that there are some potential voter
irregularities in Allegheny County which
has a giant chunk of the electorate lam
a former federal prosecutor and Marine
Corps veteran ran as a moderate
distancing himself from Minority Leader
Nancy Pelosi while promising to work
with the president who won here in 2016
backing Trump's tariffs and avoiding the
alienation of his voters to find common
ground
almost everywhere Americans the state
Democratic party chair claims the blue
wave of 2018 began in Pennsylvania with
lambs win and in Washington National
Party leaders are looking with hope
toward November we have quite a few kind
of lambs running out there we do have
the caliber of individuals out there
running for active office but on the
other side of the aisle so cones likely
loss is reverberating it's a 20-point
tromelin district that's as Republicans
reflect on what it could mean for the
midterms both of these people both of
these candidates the Republican the
Democrat rayna's conservatives rain has
pro-gun pro-life anti-nazi Pelosi
conservatives and I think that's that's
the takeaway we see here the NRCC says
election officials for all four counties
have agreed to a set comb campaign
request to impound ballots and machines
and Republicans continue to seek
information regarding voting
irregularities Bret Molly thank you